what's up we are today we're doing the
wire
auto complete interview interview let's
go
oh good morning
[Music]
i don't know what is the question korean
teapot
man yeah these members most handsome
guys
who in monsta x has a tattoo tattoo
minion and i am
[Music]
i
perfection
is popular in korea hey
yes what is the question of course we
are popular
we're star we're superstar superstar
in korea korea is our career
oh wow
we made our debut by a survival
program what name is no mercy
and literally the program was annual
mercy
it was tough yeah all members
are multiple positioned
in lots of junior and we can say we came
around we could dance we can
laugh we can cry we can do everything we
can love
too how did i even get into mozart
wow
what i just said previously i joined
that
program in the middle uh not even the
middle
at end of the program and lots of people
hated me
how did i get into sex
well whatever love this is my brazil i
am
musa
really yes today right now oh yes you're
growing
up yes stop there
please stop it and then your muscle
no just talk how did most eyes get
[Music]
and then our chat room my master
is minion english major is i am
where is monsta x from we're from korea
we're from starship
korea and then monday oh my god
[Music]
we are living together but we are living
uh
half half separated yeah three three is
living in another
dorm we living in another dorm room
speak english spanish of course
is made by troy
does most likes have siblings yes
women all have brothers but we don't
have sister
only brothers only brother
[Music]
libra scorpio paprika boy
thank you
[Music]
the cartoon manager came to our concert
and i had an opportunity to
join that huge program
it was a great experience such an honor
for us because we grown by that
cartoon you know seriously and it's
really popular yeah
yeah why
[Music]
our fans suggested that bank to our
company and our company should step
again oh we will
yes
at that time yeah we were so not happy
in english lots of american fans
uh including the european speak all
english
but we wanted to approach them too
in a more friendly way like
with some language that
we all can sing and speak and listen so
we think we try to
release our english album and we had a
good deal with epic reports so
well some of the questions
were very basic yeah
very very basic hope this interview
made you satisfied all your curious
about
things about us please go check out our
ladies
album one of a kind thank you bye
you